en la ciudad de brandenburgo en la
antigua Alemania del este se lleva a
cabo una vigilia por el fin de la guerra
en Ucrania para estos militantes de
izquierda protestar por la paz Es
sinónimo de frenar la exportación de
armas a kiev
Aquí está nuestra petición contra la
guerra y la participación de Alemania en
la guerra no queremos esta guerra ni que
llegue hasta nosotros queremos que nos
proteja
en esta región que estuvo encerrada en
el bloque soviético antes de la caída
del muro de Berlín demora la tercera
guerra mundial parece omnipresente los
manifestantes hacen eco de la visión de
la historia del presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin
la otan se creyó la gran ganadora cuando
cayó el muro y no cumplió las promesas
hechas a gorbachov de no expandirse
hacia el este eso no es poner excusas
pero Putin dejó que pasara durante años
antes de reaccionar
la antigua alemanía del este se
construyó sobre el antiamericanismo y la
amistad con Rusia hasta 1989
del gobierno alemán a Ucrania preocupa
muchos y cada vez a más el pasado sábado
en Berlín una multitud de 13.000
personas se unió en una manifestación
organizada por esta diputada destaca
activista antiotan
el movimiento pacifista tiene que
reclamar la calle pero en medio de
símbolos pacifistas banderas rusas y
algunos miembros de la extrema derecha y
la extrema izquierda persuadir a los
votantes para que apoyen a Ucrania es un
reto dice esta diputada de la mayoría
gobernante ella también creció en lo que
alguna vez fue Alemania del este
nuestro pasado se refleja nuestra forma
de ver las cosas y el problema hoy es
que mucha gente no diferencia entre
Rusia y Putin pero no es el pueblo ruso
el que atacó Ucrania sino Putin es el
único culpable y tenemos que seguir
explicándolo
el gran cambio político que el
cancillero comenzó hace un año no cuenta
con el apoyo de la mayoría en el este
una encuesta sugiere que el 59% se opone
al envío de tanques pesados alemanes a
Ucrania